let me ask this question you're a lawyer
okay and when something like this
happens to your kid you're going to
spend how many hours have you spent
studying the whole motive everything
that's going on with this how many hours
have you put into this whole thing since
that happened with your daughter two
years okay so give me give me total
hours what's hours what would you say
actual hours couple thousand hours easy
easy okay so here's here's my question
my question is motive right yesterday
we're at the debate and we're watching
all these guys and we're watching and
everything that's going on and we're
kind of studying what's going on with
the marketplace right now and what is
the motive of this person saying this
what is the motive of that person doing
this what is the motive of this okay the
motive here is that guy wants to make
money off of me okay cool I get it great
what's the motive of this guy this
person wants to get close to you because
they're trying to get close to a person
that works with you and you want them to
introduce you to her because they really
like her all right so you want me to
endorse you that you can okay I get your
motive I want motive what is the motive
of trans what is the motive of going to
the kids is it is it purely business
because we just read the numbers how big
it is right the the the uh uh hormone
hormone replacement therapy 10.2 billion
in 2019 it's going to be higher than
that today you got the male to female
gender reassignment surgery is a $190
million in 2019 and just getting warmed
up and getting warmed up we can say
finances but it's got to be more than
that what do you think it is so it's
this is why it's so difficult to destroy
because it's a multi-headed Hydra so you
have the money there's huge amounts of
money I mean we have uh David Sachs um
his craft Ventures just uh invested in
Plume the online seller of uh hormones
that targets kids even though it's
supposed to be 18 above it targets kids
because I lurk in that space there's a
huge amount of money in esgs so everyone
or all these companies think that
they're getting good guy points for esgs
while fixing their envir environmental U
footprint is really expensive social's
very inexpensive governance is is
relatively inexpensive so they're
picking the social so they'll they'll
throw a pride parade I mean that's how
they can get their good guy points um so
you have money I mean there are you're
right there are there's billions of
dollars riding
on vulnerable kids and vulnerable adults
because this is adults too we can't
actually stop at 18 18 to 25 this stuff
should be banned most of these kids are
autistic most of them have mental health
issues um going back years that are not
being resolved so we have money so we
that's an easy one to figure out we also
have Government funding this in the
state of California we have to the tune
of multitude of millions of dollars
pouring into this industry whether
they're building new foster care
facilities for these kids that they're
stealing from parents um whether it's
anti-hate and they're siphoning this off
to NOS or nonprofits so the the money is
a huge part of it then we just talked
about the sex because sex and money go
together just like you know peas and
carrots um there's always a sex
component of it like I said when you
take these vulnerable girls and
boys I mean you pump a boy with sex as
what sexual desires or sex what do you
mean by sex okay in two ways so the boys
they're pumping these boys with puberty
blockers their bodies never grow into a
man body they have Micro sized um
penises um and and they never grow and
this is a fetish movement so the top
porn right now is transgender porn so
these men could be 30 years old but they
look like little boys and you you have
um like links back to like that aspect
of it on even like the top sites you
have W paath which is World professional
association for transgender health I
believe is the what the acronym stands
for um on their latest guidelines they
advocated that unic is a valid gender
identity even for children and if you
followed the links back that they first
posted it went directly to a fetish site
of grown men talking about how they
wanted to castrate young boys wait what
unic unic unic for real for real for
boys that so a castrated male
essentially is what a unic is um yeah it
goes back to history the Egyptians
wanted strong men to protect the queen
but they would castrate them so that
they couldn't hook up with and you you
have you have the top World profession
Association for transgender health so w
paath that in their latest guidelines
were advocating for unic as a valid
gender identity and you linked back and
it linked you checked the link on it
that I doubt it's still up now because
I'm sure they tried I'm sure they tried
to wipe it did they keep up no it's it's
it's still there so we have sex
money we have um calling the herd we
have Eugenics because we had a dtrans
awareness
uh you know event 10 out of the 11d
transitioners were there were autistic
if they went through with their
transition they would all be sterilized
so let's call The Herd remember plant
Parenthood is the biggest seller of of
cross- seex hormones and plant
Parenthood had its Genesis in
Eugenics sterilizing the deplorables The
Unwanted um the poor the mentally unwell
so you have that aspect of it and then
we have queer Theory which is the
destruction of everything that's normal
the destruction of the
family when my child was going through
this she was told to call me by my first
name so that she I was no longer mother
so she could separate this is a a this
is designed to blow away everything that
is good in the world we see queer Theory
going on right now when you see all
these uh protests in in support Court of
Hamas um this is queer Theory again it
has to keep queering it they have to
keep um finding something that's good
and destroy it destroy the family
destroy the child destroy education keep
destroying it's designed to keep
snowballing until there's nothing left
of our society first amendment being
destroyed but why though actually go why
because okay these same people that want
to do this they also want to make money
okay if you destroy Society you're no
longer going to make money you're going
to make you're going to lose a lot of
your money why would you do that like
you can't have a society of people that
are not working that are you know that
that can't be a net positive to society
why would they do that well that's where
the the aspect of belief comes in at
least in my opinion is one in the in the
transgender aspect you are making a
permanent patient out of someone so even
if like oh well you can't have kids now
okay then we'll just push you down the
line to IVF or sergy or anything else
that will provide money um it is making
a permanent patient because
medicalization in this sense breeds
medicalization you know you have
complications from surgery better have
another surgery you're still
uncomfortable with something better have
another procedure you have you know you
have side effects from taking hormones
well we got to get you on more
medication to fix that um you know it's
it's all of this stuff and it is it is
essentially when when we talk about
essentially you know ruining or queering
the normal it is taking perfectly
healthy body and destroying it and and
the money the money is coming from
People of Our Generation those of us who
who worked you know 10 12 hours a day
and worked their tails off we're paying
for all of this eventually that money
will dry up so it will end uh but
they're taking our tax dollars and using
our tax dollars to harm harm kids um and
to pay for these medical interventions
using that term loosely in in California
and and and in Most states medical pays
for this so those are our tax dollars
being used when you're paying for your
private insurance your private insurance
is paying for this you're we're paying
into this Oli I don't I mean you had so
many surgeries were they paid by your no
I paid myself yeah to pay yourself so
NIH didn't do that uh no no no not for
um because I was changing my nose like I
had six nose jobs I was doing Jewel
feminization they weren't doing that no
NIH time he's in London a National
Health Service yeah NH yeah
yeah so the motive is based on what
you're saying is money ESG social sex
boys are being pumped to puberty
blockers because their body now grows to
human bodies microp penises top porn
sites as transgender porn you were going
to give a second Point under sex what
was a second one well then the other
thing is then there's another as as Luca
was was bringing up too is there's money
made on the front end and there's money
made on the oh God like a pipeline of a
funnel of other products I can sell you
it is a nonstop so also I'm going to get
a little deep here but with the parents
so you you you you break up the parents
and the child so the child runs away
goes into foster care or or goes a
glitter family yes but the parent has to
take all these parenting courses so the
parent is always spending money in the
court systems and hiring people and
hiring attorneys to try to get their
child back they never get their child
back there's so much money in this it's
kind of hidden money um the prisons are
paying for all these gender uh
Transformations for men so that they can
get into women's uh women's prisons
again like plume um the hormone company
is is uh working with stor so they take
they sterilize you and then they buy you
a baby when you want one so there's so
much money to be made on on people
misery over and over and over again I
mean the D transitioners like Luca said
the doctors don't even know what to do
to help her they they don't I so I went
when I first detransitioned I I went to
a doctor that was at the gender clinic
at my current University because I was
like you know I got off testosterone I
was like I need blood work done I need
to see where my levels are at I knew
exactly you know like what I needed for
that um just to see what what what
damage was done essentially is what I
needed to see and um I went there and I
I was candid I just I just explained
everything to this doctor I'm like this
is what is going on and um she she
looked at me and she said you know um I
want I want to help you but I have no
idea what to do with you there's no
protocol for this and I I am actually
also one of the D transitioners who went
back to the original Octor which is not
very many of us and what did the
original doctor say this is just the
next step on your gender Journey wow um
is what I is what I got told and no no
real help was offered um and here's the
thing like at the time I went back to
that clinic I was still pretty newly
detransitioned and I I would have been
willing to like okay you know what maybe
maybe this doctor's different maybe she
will help me maybe she would understand
and instead she looked mildly panicked
through like the Zoom call cuz this
wasn't even in person um she looked
mildly panicked that I even brought up
that I didn't think I could consent to
this stuff um at at 16 with all my
mental health issues going on and told
me that this is the next step of my
gender journey and then I had to pay for
the zoom call appointment which was a
lot and I'm sorry I was going to make a
point regarding that so also these
hospitals they don't want to treat d
transitioners because it makes their
statistics and data look bad so you see
all of these clinics trans activists
they'll claim there's a 1% D transition
rate why do you think that is it's
because they're not actually treating
them they just send them out the door
sorry we can't help you we can't
reconstruct your breast the Medicaid or
Medicare isn't going to pay for that
reconstruction so they don't want those
statistics and you know that's what
trans activists always argued as a 1% D
transition rate but but we know there
are so many there's a a Reddit group
online with 50,000 people in the D
transition Forum I believe it's higher
than that now it's higher now this is
the medical economy this is the dark
side of the medical economy that we all
saw during coid where hospitals wanted
to declare deaths related to coid
because it helped them help their
statistics and their Federal grant money
on the other side so there's this whole
dark economy that's a word it keeps
coming to mind as I'm listening to you
it's like there's this dark economy the
dark trans economy it's pure arrogance
by the way to say uh this is what
Wikipedia the transition is more common
in the early stage of transition
particularly before surgery the share of
trans people who Le transition is
unknown which estimates generally
ranging as less than 1% to as many as 8%
and then right below that of course you
have the gender GP link um it which is
which is what is go to the gender GP
links let's see what that is a trans
it's a transa it's a trans activist
group um but it's it's funny cuz some of
the major studies on studying quote
unquote D transition uh don't even
include it like didn't even include
people who actually um identified as D
transition like there was the like
National transgender survey that was
going around around this time last year
um and by virtue of being a d
transitioner and no longer being part of
that you could not even respond meaning
that they do not they are not even
counting D transitioners in this number
because it was supposed to gauge how
well how many people are there um and
then you don't get an answer of okay
well here's how many D transitioners
there I'm I'm trying to look up the how
just how many people are now in the in
the D subreddit because even since I
joined it last year it is it is shot up
um is that number public can can that it
is public so it currently has 51k
members on
r/d um on the dtrans members 51,000
members 51k members on r/ and last year
it was uh
37,000 um so it keeps growing I mean it
just keeps growing and there is one
there is one study that they did through
the military where they showed the
number of military personnel that went
on cross- seex hormones and then stopped
coming for their cross- seex hormones
and that's 30% so they're hiding they're
hiding the true numbers because again
it's a cult and they can't have anybody
saying that transition isn't great the
the D subreddit is what I you know
lovingly refer to as one of the most
depressing places on the internet um the
what one of the most depressing places
this is the GP trans no the D subreddit
because there is a we we have each other
but aside from that there is a total
lack of Hope is something you find in D
train communities you have people
who are
suffering so many health problems caused
but as many of them were going through
the darkest time in their lives when
they were pulled into all this thing
many of them were
children and you you see them come out
the other end and they are just broken
and desperately searching for some to
hold on to and all this they are
desperately searching for some hope it
gets better and some
hope that it you know that there is help
out there when you have a medical system
that is looking Us in the eyes and
telling us that it doesn't want to help
us that we are just the collateral
damage for a social movement that it
doesn't care how many of us are hurt and
you go to this forum and you read the
stories of the actual people who have
been hurt by this the actual human lives
that have been destroyed by this
treatment and the fact that you just you
just see the activists that are just
like collateral damage and then you have
to ask how many people will be enough
for them to actually care how many
because this has like Aaron was talking
about I think you even were paying
attention that he trans celeberate
before even ID transitioned um and you
just you look at you look at the numbers
shooting up of
people people doing this and you see the
real harm that's caused and you wonder
how many more people are going to be
hurt until you you know give a crap and
notice and maybe even acknowledge that
something has gone wrong here the
horrifying irony of this is so massive
to me right now that these people are
authentically hurting authentically
physically harmed by the treatments and
the drugs and medications and they're in
this dark place which is what they
wanted you to believe you were in at the
start I I never oh you're lost no one
cares about about you we do I I never
was truly suicidal until I I
detransitioned and was having to deal
with the real consequences of things
like joint pain so bad I couldn't get
out of bed last winter of things like
pelvic pain so bad I was curled over in
the curled up in the fetal position on
the couch until realizing that I may
have destroyed my chance completely of
having children until realizing that
parts of my body are gone that there was
nothing wrong with there was nothing
wrong with my body and it was cut up and
having to come to terms with that and
God thank God I'm in a much better place
now and thank God I have people in my
life and some of the other D
transitioners that like understand what
I'm going
through but the medical industry has
essentially created a you know a
destroyed subset of human with lifelong
health issues and lifelong almost trauma
surrounding their body now and kicked
them out the back door because it
doesn't look good on their
stats here here's the thing too I get
phone calls from D
transitioners that are
suicidal the I mean they are literally
suicidal they call me I can't go on I
won't leave my house I don't know what I
am I have removed all my body parts
there's a young man in San Francisco who
called two Fridays ago um he was in a
psychotic break moment when he uh let
them uh remove his G
he's
29 he's a straight guy what do I say to
him what do I say to him to help keep
him
alive after the doctors have done this
to them and like Luca said and then they
throw him to the curb sorry we can't
help you it was your decision your
autonomous decision we were just the
surgeons we just did what you said to do
I mean these doctors need to be held to
account first Do no harm we do not have
cafeteria
style medical procedures you can't walk
in I mean we shouldn't no one should
walk in and say Hey I want my body parts
removed yeah I I mean I agree and this
is often the only support these kids
have is going to these dtrans forums or
you know there's very little support
because what happens just going back to
the cult is if that person speaks out
online firstly they get cancelled they
get bombarded with hate so that's in an
effort to silence them secondly we have
to remember if they're trans most of
their Friendship Circle is likely still
going to be trans or non-binary so for
them to go against their friends is
basically you know they're going to be
Blacklist they're going to be completely
canceled so they have no one to speak to
so that's why they go online they're
speaking with people anonymously and
they can't get that mental health
support and you know they are really
struggling with the mental health what
got you through it you talk about faith
a little bit but what got you through
these days um to be honest it was really
really tough you know I went through
some very dark times you know doing all
these crazy crazy surgeries you know
being left with the scars and it was
really really tough and one of the
things that helped me is kind of having
reminiscence therapy so you kind of
think back to when you young you know
happy memories so when I was a little
kid I would you know revisit places I
went to like museums or you know Farms
or fields and stuff and having that
reminiscent therapy and I went to a
church I went to as a kid with my school
and I went there and was rekindling
these happy memories and thinking you
know I was a happy person back then I've
been miserable for about 20 years I need
to snap out of it so you know the faith
was and just having that purpose in life
and I thought you know what what I'm
doing is a bad role model you know I'm
taken to Tik Tok I'm trans I'm sharing
this online and stuff and that could
actually hurt someone that could
actually influence someone I I I want to
do two things okay if if we're already
this far along uh I I want to explain it
as well so women who go through the
transition of being a man okay you
explained the surgery what was it called
it's it's a uh what was the name of it
uh phalloplasty phalloplasty
phalloplasty and Tom explained this to
me for the first time yesterday I had no
clue that's how they did it by the way
where they cut a a a you know uh the
horrifying isn't it yeah can you and
then and for women uh for men being uh
uh girls where if you don't constantly
you know do certain procedure it could
shut down then you can't PE then you
have you know all these other things
that you could be dealing with when one
wants to go through that procedure what
does that procedure look like see um
when it well when it comes to the the
female to male identifying one um from
my understanding is it is a series of
surgeries um that like it takes a it
takes a graph and it leaves behind a ton
of scarring whether it be on your
forearm or I believe on your thighs in
another place I to be honest I never
looked into to it because they even when
I was like believed I was trans
completely I was like well that is
absolutely horrifying I don't want that
done um oh
no
um but yeah it's it's it's terrifying it
is these have such high talking about
they have such high complication rates
too you see people going in revision
after revision after rision you see you
see surgeons that always do like a
terrible job and are known to do a
terrible job of these things in the
community except trans people are shut
down whenever they talk about their
health issues or like these bad surgeons
cuz they think it's going to look bad on
the rest of the community and that is
why r/d TR is also a place where like
you're hearing about some of these
health issues that transition causes
that get shut down in trans circles
because you might scare someone and they
might not transition if they knew that
if they knew the health effects and our
shocking research on phow plasty say
that 40% of the time they end up in
continent because they can't because
they lose control of the muscle that we
all release when it's time to pee yeah
they also bleed they have a lot of
cramps um they have to constantly go to
the toilet and they're basically in pain
for the rest of their life and then if a
man becomes uh with woman parts you know
vagina plasty they have to use a dilator
every single week for the rest of their
life and there was a case if you know
Jazz Jennings who has the reality TV
show you know and her mom who has
transitioned since she was a kids and
also encourages other parents to
transition their kids she was bragging
about it you know joking about it and
you can see this this young kid you know
she's about 18 19 Now jazz Jennings she
is really really suffering with her
mental health you see it on the screen
and it's heartbreaking and the mom is
bragging that oh don't worry you can use
a dilator and that's the reality of what
these uh people that transition have to
go through they're never going to be
able to have these parts functioning
normally they're always going to have
complications they're going to be in
pain and again there's no treatment for
that because these doctors don't want to
help them you know once they've done the
operation you know you're out the door
they don't want you on as a statistic as
a D transitioner um also when well
one thing that the phrasing at least
that I liked is um I I have a friend who
D transitioned and he he's referred to
essentially the entire thing
specifically the bottom surgeries as a a
sexual labotomy your function is gone it
is
destroyed um he he's referred to the
process of gender transition as a sexual
labotomy and I think that is a a very a
very good way to phrase it because of
the fact that it is a physical
intervention that is destroying a part
of you for what is a mental health
condition and for the young for for
young boys who go on puberty blockers
and then cross- sex hormones we talked
about the lack of growth but they also
never will achieve um a climax so how do
you get how do you get consent from a
10-year-old how do you explain if you're
going to go on these puberty blockers
and 95% go on to cross- seex hormones so
once you're on puberty blockers you're
going on cross- seex hormones that you
will never experience a sexual pleasure
how do you explain to a 10-year-old what
that means to give something up there
you have no idea what it is there and
this is I believe forever how do you
explain that how do you define an orgasm
um I believe this was out of the UK one
of their conclusions but there is no
there is no age appropriate way to
explain to a child what the complete
loss of their sexual function as an
adult is there's no age appropriate way
to explain it whether that be you know
the boys on Purity blockers who will
never develop that way whether it be
putting young girls on testosterone to
the point where they have atrophy so bad
that it doesn't matter they're not going
to be able to do things anyway so it's
it's terrifying and there is no there is
no age appropriate way to explain that
to a child and also it's one of those
things where like why are we you know
listening to a young child young
teenager young child's judgment when
that when that that kid is saying they
don't want to have kids
of course they don't want to have kids
they're a child themselves they haven't
gotten a chance to grow up and know what
that means and we are destroying not
only their sexual function but their
fertility before they have even gotten a
chance to mature and get to the point
where they can have the long-term
decision making to decide if that is
something they even want yeah I mean to
me it goes back down to the
responsibility the parents and these
parents have issues they they they
sincerely have issues they need to be
diagnosed to see what they're going
through now some of them that are just
worried and they're like oh my God what
do I do I don't want my kid to you know
kill themselves suicide totally get it
they have the fear but there's a certain
responsibility